[音楽]
3位
みんな嬉しそうですね
これは僕はいらしてでみんなで作った
日本ではじめての全寮制のインターナショナルスクールアイザックの卒業式の光景です
自然に囲まれたかレーザーの中で
39カ国110人以上の子どもたちが集まって
デザイン線キングやマインドフルネスリーダーシップもなんで次世代のリーダーを
目指して頑張っています
色んな国の文化も育ちも違う
子どもたちが集まっているんでいろんなことが起こります
例えば
インドのアート部カースト最下層から来た12歳の子どもは
めく国際会議でインド人を黙らせるのと日本人を喋られするのが一番難しいって言うん
ですけれども
二幼虫は本当にずっと発表しててずっとてあげてもほんと元気すぎて大変だったですね
ところがランチになると全然食べないんです
それで代表理事の小林りんちゃんが
和食は口に合わないのっていう風に聞いたら
急に泣き始めちゃったんですねというのは小さい時から今だけしか食べたことがない
から
胃袋が小さくてでも個人で絶対に残しちゃダメだっていうふうに教育を受けてるから
必死で食べようとしているんですけども食べられなくて泣き出してしまったんですね
ん
それを見ていた隣の他の家の良い人の女の子は実はいろいろ悩んでいて
登校拒否にになってたんですけれど
その後代表理事の小林りんちゃんところに来て
自分がいかに恵まれているかというのが初めてわかったと
今後どうやって人生きていくか真剣に考えたいというふうに言ってきたそうです
投資家である僕がどうして全然畑違いの学校をつくろうと思ったかと言いますと
いろんな企業家を見ていてハグリィで才能のある起業家は本当にすごいな
そう考えると発展途上国のハングリーで才能のある子どもたちというのは世界を変える
リーダーになりうる世界の宝だなって言う
気持ちがすごく強くなったからです
そういう子どもたちに日本で教育の機会を与えて
先進国の子供たちも一緒に勉強したら
対応性の中で色んなことを感じに学ぶ
素晴らしい格好ができるんじゃないかと思ったからです
学校作るとなると子どもたちに幸せになってもらうことが一番大切ですそれで初めて
何が幸せかっていうのを考えて3つ
キーワードがあるなと思うようになりました
一つ目は絆
これは友達でも彼女でも家族でも地域貢献でもなんでもいいんだと思います
だらエラーみたいに宇宙につながってる人はホント幸せだろうなというふうに思います
自分よりも
大きな何かとつながっているっていう感覚は幸せの大前で
だと思います
二つ目は成長
80歳になってもより良い寿司を目指して自分の寿司を作っている
寿司職人の方っていうのは人生を通じてとても
シェアはせなんじゃないかと思いますいくつになっても少しでもいいからなんらかの
成長感じられるというのは幸せのとても大きな要素だと思います
3つ目は社会の基準に関係なく自分を表現するということ
今日はこのことについてお話ししたいと思います
投資家として常々も授業誰がやるかに尽きるなっていうのはずっと感じていたんですが
アイザックの場合は古馬椅子凛ちゃんという素晴らしい
リーダーに出会えてとても幸運でした
彼女こそ社会の記事に関係なく120%自分を表現する人でした
最初彼女はアジアの社会起業家を育てるファンドをつくりたいということで僕のところ
に相談に来ました
ずっと学校会える人を探していた僕は
彼女の人を動かす力に感銘を受けて
ぜひ学校を作らないかという話をしました
アジアで
才能があるハングリーな子供たちに教育の機会を与えて
あげたら装置の一部はひょっとしたら国に戻ってその国のリーダーになるかもしれぬ
そしたらその方がずっと長い目で見たら社会にインパクトを与えられるし
凛ちゃんが本当にやりたいことに近いんじゃないかっていう話をして説得しました
最初彼女びっくりしてましたが
学校の理念にすごく共感してくれて
で代表を引き受けてくれることになりました一旦第二になるともう本当ものすごい勢い
で学校の立ち上げに奔走し始めてまず
ベンチャー企業の経営を生かしてでそのままスタッフやといい次に不動産中
やってきた経験を生かして
途中かいい校舎を建て
それから uwc やスタンほどの経験を生かして世界中から先生を連れてきて
ユニセフの経験を生かして
サマーキャンプの学生を連れて来てっていうふうにもカードやってきたことを全部使っ
てもうほんとダンプカーのように次々と実行していきました
今やもう彼女は自分が行ってきたけど全部使っているんで
自分はこの学校を作るために生まれてきたっていうふうに言っているくらいです
そんな彼女を見ていて不当スティーブジョブスの有名な
スタンほどスピーチのコネクティング dots の話を思い出しました
ジョブスが
大学の時にカリグラフィーのクラスは学んでそれが10年
マックを作る時に2座に蘇ってきて
思いがけずすごく役に立ったっていう話です
僕はこれはずっと
過去やったことが自然とつながるっていう教訓だと思っていました
でもりんチャー見ていて120%自分を表現する人っていうのは
.が自然と繋がるんではなくて自ら
自分で.つなげていくんだなというふうに思うようになりました
ジョブズの場合にもよく考えてみたらあんなに自体の数がなくてもマックはヒットした
かもしれないと思うんですよ
でも大事なのは
ジョブズが自分はんだことを全て使って120%自分を表現した
だからこそ世界中の人が感動するような素晴らしいコンピュータができたい
同じようにピンちゃんも虫もダートとかだし行ってから
校舎立てずに俳句を使ってオーダーとでクリエイティブな校舎を作りとかそういうのも
アリだと思うんですけどでも大事なのは彼女がこれまでやってきたことを全部使って
120%自分を表現したからこそアイザックも素晴らしい学校になろうとしている
これまでやってきたことをすべて突きこんで自分は110%表現するそれこそが
コネクティング dots の本当の意味なんじゃないかと思うようになりました
もう1人僕がとても尊敬している自分の友人で
オランダ人のボリスギーと1さんの話をさせてください
彼は lgbt の活動家で
ヒューマンライツウォッチっていう国際人権団体の活動で僕は彼てしやっても彼の生き
方に本当に感銘を受けました
ポリスは大学生の時までは自分でも自分がゲイだっていうのを
認めることができず女の子とを付き合ってたそうです
ためか留学中にたまたま制定された
ゲーム集会でその芸のリーダーに突然指をさされてお前はゲイだ俺には分かるっていう
風に言われたそうです
びっくりしてボリスはその場を立ち去ったのですがやっぱり自分はゲイだと思って終え
告白することを決めますしたなんとちょうどその時に親から手紙をご覧です
その手紙には今日 d とにつけては
本当に関しことがあったとそれはお前の姉さんがレズビアンであるということを骨格し
たとこれでもお姉さんからは子孫は生まれないと
でもいいニュースもあるとそれはボリスという素晴らしい息子がいて彼が必ず
ディートリヒ系を反映させてくれるだろうと書いて新しいです
その手紙を受け取ってポリスをはが悲しむのを考えて合格するのをやめて
また勉学に励んででオランダに帰って国際弁護士になって
社会の模範のような成功した人生を歩ん d ました
ちょうどその頃
テレビニュースを見ていると
ゲイのリーダーガサツされたというニュース見て彼は衝撃を受けるんですね
殺されたのはハーヴェイミルク
有名な lgbt の活動家で佐浦椅子の市会議員だった人です
その魅力こそがゴルフを指差して
お前はゲイだって言ったその彼だったんですね
て彼はもうそれを見て突然自分はミルクが果たせなかったことをやるために生まれてき
たというふうに思ったらしくてそれで今度は前はず上にカミングアウトつします
親が案の定をすごく嘆くのを見て
ボイスは
親がこれだけうあやみを自分の強みに変えてみせるというふうに誓ったそうです
それから彼は社会派の弁護士に代わって
ゲイとして初めて最高裁の判事になり
同性婚を成立させるためにゲートして初めての国会議員なりついに
連立野党の党首になります
そこで
同性婚の法律をついに議会で通してオランダは世界で初めて同性婚を認める国になり
ます
その後首位で
主そうなるんじゃないかという期待もあったのにブリスあっさり議員を辞めて
今度は
国際人権団体に入って世界中の lgbt の人たちの人権を守るために本当に世界中
を奔走してみよう危険をまあロシアとかアフリカとかいったリスクも3のキーを押下し
たからもう
奔走してその活動をしています
その活動が認められてついにゲートし始めてごらん台上から
ないとの昭王
いました
お堀さ
社会の基準に関係なく時510%表現している
素晴らしい例だと思うんですね
lgbt の人はホント大変で社会の基準に合わせをがありません
だからこそ
一旦カミングアウトすると
社会の基準になく関係なく自分を表現できる
ある2位弱みを強みに変えている僕は
これからのリーダーっていうのはマイノリティーから出てくると思うんですね
マイトにいた人たちは自分を表現するハードルが音速高い分
一旦する乗り越えると今度は無茶くせに自分を表現できる
で傷ついた痛みを本当に知っているからこそ本当に強くて
優しい
現在社会は行き過ぎた資本主義にいる戻しが起こっていると思うんですね
力による支配とかあまりにも大きな貧富の差にもうこの人は疲れ切っていると思います
だからこそ対応性の中で痛みがわかる
リーダーというのはこれから活躍すると
思いますここで僕が
強調したいのは110%自分を表現する
リーダーっていうのはいわゆるリーダー大会社の経営者とか政治家とかそういう
いわゆるリーダーではないっていうことです
これからのリーダーっていうのは
自分自身のリーダーになってありのままの自分を表現する人だと思います
つ5 e cheers 後人社会の基準に影響されて自分がいわゆるリーダーになり
たいと思いがちだと思うんですけれども
男でも女でも選挙中になりたいのであればそれが一番幸せだシーン
社会にとってもそれが一番素晴らしいことだと思う
思います
1人人が1人が
社会に基準に関係なく自分のやりたいことを見つけ
120発の自分を表現する宇宙船地球大の乗組員として宇宙が有力
なる方向に一人でも多くの人がありのままの自分を表現できるようになれば夜中は
もっとよくなると思います
こうやって人の話ばかりしてきましたが僕自身はどうかというとなかなかあの自分で
やることを見つけられずずっと苦労しています
ポリスやジョブズみたいに一つもであり続ける人にずっと憧れて自分にとってそれは何
かなというのをずっと探して来たんですけれども
まあ好奇心が多すぎてなかなか一つのことが続けられずずっと悩んできました
でも愛咲ある時にこのエドワーズ杉さんという間地下に出会って
建築家っていうのはその人のために家を
作るいくつも作る仕事だな壮大なエヴァ僕もん菌近いになりたいなと思うようになり
ました
本当はねもうむちゃくちゃかっこいいですほんとあの
ルックスもこうなれたら一番良いんですけどね
で僕にとっての良い作品っていうのは110発で自分を表現する人が増えるような場所
を作るっていうことです
主役は活躍する人ってそういう場所
良い作品をいくつも作るっていうのが自分にとっての自分の120%の表現かなと思う
ようになりました
これまで作った作品としては
を変えデザインだったりキャンパス51だったりアイザックであったり
ライフネットであったりスタジオ与儀だったりするんですが
まあここで活躍する人とかここに来てくれている人たちのことを考えると幸せな気分に
なります
ボリスは自分の
メールの最後に積んこのメッセージをつけています
teacher is 基本飛ばす5インサイドバス
皆さんの中には僕と同じようにまだ自分がやりたいことを
見つけられていない方もいらっしゃるかと思います
でも子ですがいいみたいにそれは皆さんの心の中
自分自身の中にあるんだと思います
自分にとってより大切なものを少しずつ選んでことによっていつもにかだんだんと
見つかるもんじゃないかなというふうに思っています
最後に僕は自分指針に沿いているメッセージを送らせてください
one life enjoy the faith 飛ぶリアライズみます付
fun life には2つついにがあります
一つは一回しかない人生
もう一つは自分も周りの人も動物も植物も地球も宇宙も一つ
そういう風に考えると
自然と
すべてのもに対する哀悼リスペクトが感じられますよね
enjoy っていうのは誰だ楽しいっていう意味ではなくてくるシーンも全て含んで
です
僕もいい作品を作ろうと思うとジラ下手じゃなかったしていて時々
眠れなかったりもしますでもそうやって舌がで食べたしている
その過程こそが
一番充実していて成長も感じでひょっとしたら一番幸せ時間なのかもと思うようになり
ました
one life 印綬クエストデュアライズにはスフ
一度しかない人生自分も周りも一つ
より良い宇宙に向けて
自分をもっきり110%表現する旅を楽しんで
シャアせよ a
目指しましょう
ありがとうございました
[拍手]